what do you know that trusted me to give
out this next award all by myself
what exactly do i do here uh sir
uh what what do i do here what do you
mean what do you do here what took you
so long
i was in her back watching burt
lancaster's chest move
don rickers on his high class show they
must be losing their heads hey frank
this is an exciting night i met
everybody remember when you said to me
in the dressing room stand over there
and watch me smile
listen frank what do i do this is a
great night it's going on the cards you
don't come out you just come out you got
to relax frank
these are all people in the industry
look at the people in the front staring
going
who is he you gotta make yourself look
at henry mancini hello henry
i want you to know something frank you
have to relax just
say what's on the cards here it is okay
and try it and take your time can you
hold it out there just truly
when you get old you start to slip
later on we're gonna buy dick haim's
album and see what's wrong with your
career
for the best story excuse me get your
arm off i'm telling you
i mean you're big but i'm not your
cooley
well the best story and screenplay
written directly for the screen
we have here the battle of algiers you
had a line you blew it
just roll along frank and die
the alone of algae is one of my favorite
movies that's it
franco salinas
which means mussolini is alive
notice how you read the italian names
first right that's your trouble
bring on my people and for faces
john cassavetes oh he's great another
italian why don't we all have a linguine
party
you are the producers excuse me the band
better start laughing or i'm going to
blake your clarinet
you got one guy with the beard do a
miracle make the room disappear
for hot millions zara wallace and peter
used to know are they here
yes for 2001 a space odyssey stanley
kubrick and arthur c
clarke and the winner is give them a
cookie maybe they'll go away
the winner is frank don't stand there go
into a number do your big album
do harry jeans playing the trumpet and
watching his lip go bad
all right wise guy where's the envelope
frank you got to pull yourself together
here's the envelope frank
isn't that great boy sure had the big
chief worried didn't i folks
they get that way when they're big and
the winner is mel brooks for the
producers
just the best of luck now do me a favor
huh
bit 20 minutes you killed my whole thing
around the tanks will be in friday the
times
thank you very much uh i didn't trust
myself in case i went so i wrote
a couple of things here i want to thank
the academy of arts
sciences and money for this wonderful
award uh well i'll just say what's in my
heart
the bump the bump the bump
but seriously i'd like to thank
cindy glazer the producer of the
producers for producing the producers
josephine levine and his wife rosalie
for distributing
the film
i'd also like to thank zero mostel
i'd also like to thank gene wilder
i'd also like to thank gene wilder i'd
also like to thank gene wilder thank you
very much
you